[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are on site right outside our studio at
undiscovered SF's creative night market
we are super excited to be talking to
San Francisco's passerby z-- here we're
gonna be asking them thought-provoking
questions when we asked him what their
thoughts are on the direction of our
world and so much more so join me in
this exciting adventure that we're about
to embark on let's start asking if
people want to talk to us hey guys do
you want it to share your thoughts on
the direction of our world with our show
hey brother do you want to talk to us
about your thoughts on the direction of
our world no hey do you want to talk to
us about your thoughts on the direction
of our world sure all right come join us
what's your name
desi I'm Alan good to meet you guys so
desi what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world
I think we're spiraling out of control
but I think if we raise the vibrations
we can get realigned in the proper path
and what do you think we need to do to
raise our vibration get a line on that
path I think we need to get reading
touch with empathy I think in this like
digital world were like super isolated
our headphones on with our screens in
front of us
and not like really like interacting
with the surrounding environment around
us with the humans the other beings you
know all of that and Jessie are you one
of the like co-organizers of the
undiscover'd I am I am one of the
cofounders of undiscovered yeah so cool
we just talked to Aaron Orsino yeah so
he actually is a friend of mine from a
while ago and it was really interesting
seeing him walking by I was telling him
how beautiful what you guys are putting
on is as you say that we have this issue
with this connection well guess what
this creative night market that you guys
are putting on does that community
building that connect
yeah I mean that's the whole point is
that we want to engage with not only the
Filipino community but the broader San
Francisco community and like really help
kind of preserve what makes San
Francisco unique and diverse which is
culture you know and what I hope to
bring forward as a San Franciscan is
that Filipinos will help other San
Franciscans get reconnected with empathy
because everything is not something that
we can automate or necessarily redesign
with AI is something uniquely human and
you know if we're gonna be realigned in
the proper direction of our world we
need to be reconnected with our humanity
so beautifully set it yeah we're so
excited to continue seeing these
creative markets flourish we really hope
that more and more people bring together
community in this type of way it's a
very beautiful organization that you
guys are growing together thank you
cool awesome you know we actually
couldn't do it without the city of San
Francisco they're one of our biggest
supporters of making this happen that
parking lot is owned by the city of San
Francisco
they give us $130,000 a year to put this
festival together so we can make it free
for everybody so we're very lucky that
we're living in a very progressive City
where city government wants to try to do
the right thing and will actually put
their money where their mouths are boom
that's what's up yeah that we're very
grateful for the funds allocated to make
this free and to make it happen and
hopefully we can continue putting
together these types of events in the
future this is really cool desi thank
you thank you thanks for talking to us
really appreciate it yeah actually
youtube-dot-com forward-slash simulation
series and it's live right now yeah make
sure to for sure send air in the link so
you can share it with you guys but yeah
it's on youtube.com for such simulation
seriously thank you thank you cool one
of the co-organizers to start things off
that's interesting all right let's talk
to other brothers yo what's up guys do
you want to share some of your thoughts
on the direction of our world on our
show now all right
yo do you guys want to share some of
your thoughts on the direction of our
world on our show you know commercial
and overproducing agriculture and stuff
like that and this is really good stuff
you want to just kiss share a couple
moments a couple thoughts of it you're
shy okay
are you no worries do great points Aaron
we're ready we're ready we're ready okay
take care of their own selves but
they're benefiting so much done the
government but the government side do
you thing enough so the caring do you
guys okay yeah okay well I'll go I'll go
get some I'll go get other people yeah
okay okay thanks guys thank you thank
you they were there were a little bit
shy unfortunately I was trying to get
them to turn towards the camera but you
know sometimes they had they had some
good things to say hey guys do you want
to share some of your thoughts on the
direction of our world with us do you
want to share some of your thoughts of
the direction of our world with us here
Arkam do you want to share some of your
thoughts on the direction of our world
with us hey would I have a question hi
would you like to share some of your
thoughts on the direction of our world
with us we'd love to hear from you do
you guys want to share some of your
thoughts on the direction of our world
with us on the show
alright no worries hey do you guys want
to share some of your thoughts on the
direction of our world with us hey do
you guys want to share some of your
thoughts on the direction of our world
with us you're welcome
would you like to share some of your
thoughts on the direction of our world
with us on our show I have a question
you you gotta go okay all right
hey do you want to share some of your
thoughts on the direction of our world
with us on our show that Smile yes yeah
yeah it's a show called simulation we
talked to different leaders at the edge
of their fields that type of stuff so
yeah we're just no no this is just more
like a amna on the street and yeah we
are all leaders yeah
come talk to us for a couple minutes
just say some of your thoughts on the
direction of our world okay no worries
okay
do you guys want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world hi guys hi guys do you want to
talk to us about your thoughts on the
direction of our world while you're on
no okay now yeah okay
hey guys do you want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world
okay come stop by hi do you guys want to
talk to us about your thoughts on the
direction of our world okay
hey do you want to talk to us about your
thoughts on the direction of our world
[Music]
do you guys want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world hey guys do you want to talk to us
about your thoughts on the direction of
our world
hey if you guys want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world no thoughts you must have some
thoughts on the direction of our hey
brother do you want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world hello hey do you want to talk to
us about your thoughts on the direction
of our world there's a couple thoughts
subject there's so much to talk about
have a quick chat about it what about
you do you want to talk to us about your
thoughts or the direction for world okay
hold on let me ask the dog dog do you
want to talk to us about your thoughts
on the direction you want to talk to us
about your thoughts on the direction of
our world of our world
talk to us for a little bit come on one
it's fun cuz because we're just we're
we're talking about the thoughts on the
direction of our world stuff you know
it's a fun subject going in the right
direction I mean I am a baby boomer so
you guys are so lucky you got everything
there's so much freedom before we can we
can't do anything you know but now
everything written right there it's like
on the table grab it and enjoy it but
also we have to make sure it's
sustainable for the next generation oh
yeah yeah yeah you have to take care of
the next generation yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure sure yeah yeah
but we're going on on the right
direction this alley here used to be
like a junky place is so beautiful look
at the building always I had one of the
condos here
but like this place like nono place are
you trying to record me we're live
streaming right now we're have a great
conversation have a channel Oh what
channel is it oh my god I was trying to
interview your dog too but the dog was
really shy so I decided to interview you
are you a radio station we have a show
called simulation you can find us on
YouTube it's youtube.com for /
simulations just go to youtube.com for /
simulation series okay see you later bye
yeah I do
hi guys do you want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world hey guys what's up are you guys
quote are you guys organizing no can we
look at that so look at this we're doing
we're doing yeah we're doing some live
streaming to our YouTube channel right
now of this beautiful and discovered SF
creative night market do you guys want
to hear come come a little bit more into
the shot like right here yeah yeah like
right here tell us tell us what your
thoughts are on the direction of our
world a direction of our world wow that
is very deep okay not just a Filipino
community huh the world I like where
it's heading we still need more
awareness out there like I'm vegetarian
I'm all about you know trying zero waste
and basically making sure that the next
generation still has a planet to live in
so I feel like a lot of us are in that
direction especially with the Filipino
communities they have vegan food now
vegan Filipino food that's crazy
what do you think I think as humans
we've always been our own worst enemies
and will always be a part of the
solution so I'm not too concerned but we
do have the luxury of instant
communications so the the great tool
that is the Internet has allowed us to
just share a lot more information so
much faster which makes it seem like
things are either really really good or
really really bad but I think somewhere
down the line will realize that it's
it's us and it'll always just be us to
you know be the solution and the problem
what do you guys think are some of the
key things that we need to embody to
prosper most effectively to prosper um
for me because I I am a youth advocate
so I very much involved myself with the
youth and I feel like it's really them I
feel like we need to invest in the youth
more not just you know on videos or
whatever but personally you know like we
dance
with the kids we go to them to workshops
and all that stuff I recently came from
the Philippines and teach a local you
know the local kids there some hands
workshop and you know representing of
course the Filipinos here in the Bay
Area trying to go outside Bay Area to
show what that there's other world out
there and we they're not as lucky as we
are so we should appreciate it and try
our best to help out yes and to
piggyback off that I I think the more
that we realize that it is kind of in
within ourselves to sorry to to teach
our kids and to teach the future to just
value themselves and their ideas and
empower them and Bolden them to to take
chances it makes it makes life a little
easier and and to always always push
honesty honesty is one of those things
that like I know we talk about it
sometimes in the sense of like you have
to be honest or to be true to yourself
but it's really just simplifying things
you know if you like something if you
don't you know give our kids the
confidence and the ability to listen to
that inner voice and I think that will
carry on to you know making the world
whatever it should be I love your
passion about investing into the youth
that's very important yeah it's
beautiful
we're old we've already lived this thing
yeah we don't make our mistakes with the
kids too you know they have so much
power that they don't even know so
that's why we should be there platform
that way to give them confidence to use
their voice because who would not listen
to kids if they start to be like let's
save the world guys no plastic because
like who would not listen to those
voices and then we used to give us a
little bit more background on
undiscovered SF so does this use most of
the the directing team okay is most of
the
what's your name my name is princess
Ryan princess Ryan I'm Alan good to meet
you such a pleasure and princess Ryan so
what's the deal with the undiscover'd SF
creative night market is this a
community is this is most of the
organizers are Filipino and then I
believe so yes so I'm I'm one of the
people that they invited to collaborate
with them here like I said I'm very much
involved in the youth in the Bay Area
this is my brand by the way kids grew
kids grew his group what's the brand so
it's a dance production and workshop for
kids so we go around to different events
and undiscovered it is one of our
partners and we are here to just teach
the kids how to move create and express
themselves because it really gives them
that boost of confidence right away and
they're just you'll see you later we're
gonna have our workshop later so awesome
kids dancing and they were being really
creative and expressing themselves they
can do a dance battle with you that
would be really fun dance battle with a
child yes please I agree bring some of
them over here and then like I said some
of these kids which I call my
ambassadors they went with me to the
Philippines a few weeks ago and we
basically cleaned up this shoreline in
like a local province over there cuz
people it's not that they're bad it's
just that they're not uneducated about
you know where to put their trash and
that it doesn't mean if they put it in
the trash it's actually going it's just
gonna disappear a lot of them goes to
the ocean so we're trying to go out
there educate these kids to make their
community you know clean nice and clean
so with ten kids picking up these
plastics all the other kids maybe we had
like 70 kids just joined us and in 30
minutes the whole shoreline was cleaned
and everybody felt empowered and I was
like my god can we do this every day I
feel like we can you know clean the
world no but for me that was just really
empowering to see that a few people did
it and all of a sudden in ten minutes
all everybody started to join yeah you
know and I feel like that's what
undiscovered is all about you know
slowly were showing the people like hey
we're here we're not it's not just
exclusive for filipinos only but we want
to share our culture because Filipinos
are actually
for that too we love sharing you know we
love telling stories that's why we have
like these Venice area soap operas also
in the Philippines because we love to
share our culture we're just really
scared because most of the time it's the
language barrier a lot of Filipinos if
they are not perfect in their English
they they're shy they're like I I don't
know I don't know how to talk to these
people to not community don't know how
to communicate with them properly so
they tend to just kind of be on the side
and this next generation they're more
empowered now there'd be like no I have
my voice I want to say something and I
feel like that's what's happening with
undiscovered a lot of the new
generations now they're they have a
voice now because they were born and
raised here their parents from the
Philippines came here they're very shy
and reserved so I feel like it took a
long time for us to really grow as a
Filipino community but now we all have
these artists these you know rappers we
have all these entrepreneurs that are
coming out and saying hey I'm Filipino
and I just discovered that her her the
artist she's half Filipino and so yes
you you're doing incredible work taking
the kids out to do clean-up on the
Oceanside and also the kids grew very
cool where can people find kids grew
we're on Instagram kids underscore
groove and also check out our website
kids - drew comm also follow my
Instagram its this is princess Ryan so
in the Philippines I was involved in the
showbiz industry I was on TV dancing and
acting and all that stuff and when I
decided I'm gonna move to the States
I didn't want to stop doing that but at
the same time I want to pass on
something so that's when I decided that
I want to create my brand I want to you
know I want to search for these kids who
have passion who have the same passion
as I do
doesn't have to be dancing it can be art
it can be you know modeling it can be
whatever so when I found that there's
actually a bunch of kids they just don't
know who's gonna help them out then
that's when I stepped in
and because I'm so connected to you know
the showbiz industry actually got them
to dance on TV with me and perform and
you know yeah and they just had like the
experience of their life and I was like
yeah so this is what I do before and now
I'm glad that you guys got to experience
it Prince John thank you so much for
talking to us this is so fun thank you
we're we're super appreciative of what
you're doing keep up the great work
thank you yes of course let's do it
what's up everyone we're with princess
Ryan here at the undiscovered SF
creative night market we are doing an
episode on simulation series our YouTube
channel and we are recording live
streaming actually our conversation
we're talking about kids groove we're
talking about inspiring young people
around the world and so do exactly that
follow princess Ryan follow simulation
series much love everyone the Instagram
is simulation series and also you can
find us across any of the other
platforms like that as well watch this
on YouTube simulation series there that
was so fun keep up the great work when
when it gets yeah yeah and then yeah for
sure yes semi Tex
you are awesome you're awesome okay okay
bye see you Oh kids group how cool is
that ah that's so cool she was so
inspirational Wow
cleaning up the ocean sides with the
kids getting them to dance and express
themselves hi guys
do you want to share some of your
thoughts on the direction of our world
on our show okay come come and stop by
on the way back okay okay
hi guys do you want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world we would love to hear from you
come join us for a little bit who next
who next let's see hey do you want to
talk to us about your thoughts on the
direction of our world the big questions
talk to us for a little bit okay come on
Ruby I'm Alan good to meet you Ruby
come over here so Ruby what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
like you know where we're our planet and
our society is moving okay
why because I feel like no one's really
caring about as much as they should or
like how do we care about it better you
can advocate more or take more steps or
strides to like help
[Music]
and what would be a good recommendation
to help take care of our world better
you could do the little things by like I
don't know recycling or are using like
reusable things or other stuff yeah yeah
yeah those are very important and also
like alright give us your thoughts on
you know we're bringing together
community like this right at this
undiscovered Assaf night market what is
the importance of doing things like this
so you can wait you repeat the question
what's the important of bringing
together community like this bring
together a community like this is
important so you can teach people about
I don't know like our culture or what
it's about or you can learn new things
and get more educated that's great Ruby
thank you so much for talking to us
really appreciate it jxu hey do you guys
want to talk to us about your thoughts
on the direction of our world hey guys
do you want to talk to us about your
thoughts on the direction of our world
come join us for a little bit hi guys do
you want to talk to us about your
thoughts on the direction of our world
okay thank you
hi guys hello hi hi hi hello do not talk
to us for a little bit you're one of the
organizers right later maybe come come
talk to us
hey do you want to talk to us for a
little bit you're a little okay okay
okay sounds good we have a couple shy
peeps shy peeps hello hi guys you gotta
talk to us for a little bit about your
thoughts on the direction of our world
hi guys hello do you want to talk to us
her a little bit about your thoughts on
our world okay no worries hey what's up
do you want to talk to us for a little
bit about your thoughts on the direction
of our world what do you guys are about
just give me an idea idea what you guys
are about well okay so come come over
here we'll ask you ask you a question
what's your name
you're Ian okay let's look this way come
over here so Ian hello thanks for
joining us Ian what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world
well the way is going it's kind of odd
some ups and downs you know and there's
some highs and lows you know positive
you know you see I think it could be a
lot better you know as a people you know
and depending on the way they want to go
you know it all depends on a person's
heart you know what they really want to
do you know I mean it's gonna take a
joint effort maybe even the whole entire
world to change you know what would be
some of the things that we can embody to
help us move in that positive direction
together what could help
it starts with individual and it starts
by an example and it starts by actions
you know so if one person can do it we
can all can do it you know so if it's
constructive
person leading one good example and we
could just follow and make it our own
way then we could develop into our own
person and our own footsteps you know
and what would you do with your leading
by example which skills would you
display with your actions
I think the most would be love yes love
love would be a good quality and
attitude personality see it takes more
than being a good person that's for sure
you know it's gonna take a lot more it's
gonna take a lot more mental ability
powers make new adjustments but it
really love us the key in this world
that's beautiful and what can someone do
to become have a deeper love a deeper
love well
Luigi starts was treat others how the
way you want to be treated you know so
if you start treating other people with
respect and you put over people with
humility and modesty and you know you
put over one another and start
developing love and start showing love
for one another ask for your fellow man
it could possibly work
you can go ahead and say hello to
everyone people that were streaming with
right now you can find the stream at
youtube.com for slash simulation series
later if you'd like so thank you so much
for talking to us I really appreciate it
which wasn't so bad we can shine just
like that boom they'd love just like
that yeah there could be many more
people doing this and also coming along
and voicing their opinions and thoughts
and also their own ideas and what could
be better like you said yeah
and that's how we slowly make the
butterfly effect with our action yes yes
yes thank you thank you so much for
talking to us all right have a good one
see ya
alright let's find our next beeps doo
doo doo doo doo hi do you want to talk
to us about your thoughts on the
direction of our world hi guys
do you want to talk to us about your
thoughts on the direction of our world
come talk to us for a little bit tell us
what you're thinking about the direction
of our world yeah come on go I just
heard a little bit we would love to hear
from you come on a little bit yeah come
over here we have some cameras over here
what what's your name
Sandhya I'm Alan good to meet you
Sandhya okay let's start with you Sonya
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world well I think that we have a
lot to look forward to technologically
that is that a word and artistically
well we can do with that and I feel like
the direction we're moving and
everything but politically and through
capitalism we can look forward to but I
think if if our world continues to move
in the way that it is with the way that
government and corporations are ruling
us then we don't how much to look
forward to that's what I got a thing and
Sonny what would you say could be some
of these main things that we could do to
build a better world
well we can encourage the know we can
encourage our government and our
representatives to listen to us and
maybe care about the environment more
maybe listen to us when we're saying put
caps on how much co2 corporations can
emit that would help us out a lot you
know cuz global warming is not that cool
we just kind of cool and we can also
have the people the working class you
know kind of pushed for more advocate
for more from the rest of everyone yeah
that's what I guess and then how about
with water what would you say is one of
the most pressing things that we
ourselves can do to get maybe people
that are in positions of
governance or in corporations how can we
how can we voice our ourselves to them
more effectively well I think the first
thing that we could do is get out and
actually vote and not vote for the
incumbent we can actually you know vote
for new people to come in who will
listen to us we can protest we can
petition and we can try to take not just
like stances like through although it's
good just like social media and stuff
like promoting things like that box you
try to create legislative change is
important so doing that and then what do
you would you say is the importance of
doing cool things like this undiscovered
SF creative night market it's important
to support your local artist because
oftentimes they back up with the
political or a social movement for
example this event is all about bringing
together the Filipino community and
altogether bringing around people of
color and I feel like that's really
important so supporting your local
artists and your communities around you
is very important awesome Sun dia thank
you so much and you guys can find you
guys can find the content at
youtube-dot-com forward-slash simulation
series and then yeah you'll see us live
thank you thank you everyone thank you
thank you hi guys
do you want to talk to us about your
thoughts on the direction of our world
[Laughter]
hello hi hi hey do you want to talk to
us for a little bit about your thoughts
on our world we'd love to hear from you
just a couple couple thoughts short
short and sweet what's your name my name
is cliff cliff I'm Alan good to meet you
it's good to come over here for a moment
so cliff what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world um I think we've
got a lot of work to do right now our
world as a whole is other than just the
continued direction that we're going
around the Sun like other wise things
for Humanity aren't looking too great
and what do you think we can best do to
make the trajectory in a more positive
way um I mean we need to make sure that
Donald Trump doesn't have a second term
like that's one of the biggest things we
can do in this country but
across the however many states that
still have Republicans leading their
legislators and state has is like
there's work to do there and even even
in California there's plenty of work to
do
and then support our friends abroad who
have similar struggles against
authoritarianism and then what would you
say would be this like you know this
central aspect of our own day-to-day
that we could do to maybe make that
world better as well
um day to day like be better to our
neighbors like be friendlier honk the
horn less when you're driving your car
like that sort of thing and then what do
you think's the importance of putting to
other things like this community that's
happening right now
um I think it's just a great way to show
that like that there are people living
here that like sohma's a real
neighborhood like it's a community it's
not just these wide streets that people
are driving fast through like we can
close down an alleyway and have like
hundreds of people show up and like this
is actually my first time at this event
and it's awesome so glad to hear that
cliff thank you for talking to us really
appreciate it thanks for talking to us
you can find all this stuff at
youtube.com for slash simulation series
cool thank you you too
hi officers hello would any of you like
to talk to us on our show about your
thoughts on the direction of our world
this community market these types of
things No thank you for your service
thank you thank you
yo what's up do you want to talk to us
for a little bit of RA come over let's
talk to us all right all right what's
what's your name I'm Evan you're Evan hi
what's your name Kolya Kolya Evan and
Clea I'm Allan good to meet you guys I
have a question what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world I think
our world is taking both I think our
world is taking both the positive and
negative turn I think there's a lot of
good things that the world is becoming
but there's also a lot of bad things
environmentally and politically I agree
like the I'm on the negative side
because of like all the things that
we've seen especially on social media so
like they're like obviously there's a
lot of positive things that people come
out to do but like the things that like
the government doing like politically
and things that they're not helping the
world so yeah and then what's something
maybe that we can do day to day to make
our world on a better trajectory I think
people need to be more cautious and
aware of how they're taking care of the
earth I think they should treat it
because it is our home I think we're a
lot careless we don't think about the
decisions we make and so I think that's
one small thing we can do day-to-day to
make simple changes that could really
help benefit the world
yeah I agree like if you just like your
community if you want to like join clubs
or make your own like beach cleanups I
think that's really good if you just
keep like little by little like helping
the earth and yeah yeah this is our home
we have to do we have to connect to
nature to what sustains us this planet
and then what do you guys thinks the
importance of putting together community
market like this I like this event like
this event I think it's really good that
you bring like the community together
because we're like not from the city but
we're still around the bay and I think
it's really good that they're drawing
everyone in especially like celebrating
culture
there's a lot of Filipino things and
like I think it's really good that
you're coming together and in unity I
think it's a I think it's a great way to
bring diversity and like kind of educate
people of the different cultures because
I think in the Bay Area it's a very
diverse community that we live in you
know we have a good amounts of every bit
of like race and so I think that by inch
like bringing events like this by
bringing cultural aspects bringing
different aspects can really just it's
just a fun event to really get people to
understand more no more and what are
your thoughts on dirt a I don't know I
don't know too much about him but I
think from what I've heard from my
grandparents I don't know I don't I
haven't heard too many good things but I
just I don't worry I don't really know
personally thank you very much thank you
both we really appreciate you guys can
find the rest of the content on
youtube.com for such simulation series
okay thank you both hello would you like
to talk to us
hi guys would you like to talk to us
about your thoughts on humanity
hi guys would you like to talk to us
about your thoughts on humanity
okay
[Music]
hello hi do you want do you want to talk
to us about what you guys are doing here
great what's your name
edy I'm Alan nice to meet you my beet
red and those are that's where we're
live-streaming right now we're yes so ed
so teach us about six seven six candles
come oh it's a little company by my wife
and myself we're both flight attendants
the number six seven six is her employee
number and then all of these candles
smell so good over here thank you so
much
so these are named after flight
attendants in places we go to oh cool
and our candles are pure soy they'll
last along like about 60 hours in each
jar okay you guys are both flight
attendants you and your wife and 676 is
her employee number yeah and which
airlines
we're used to the Virgin America now
we're Alaska Airlines and then and then
should then what would spark the drive
for Entrepreneurship for me okay so she
always knew how to make candles what we
used to do was bring our own candles to
our layover in different cities you know
how hotels are it's clean but it's kind
of like you know you want to make it
homey because it's gonna be your home
for a day or so so we bring our own
candles make our room homey and then all
our the flight attendants would go into
our rooms and ask us like oh my god your
room smells amazing what do you guys do
and we're like well we bring our own
candles we'll make them so that's how it
kind of started they started ordering
from us and then it became a little
business
Wow so then you wanted to bring a little
bit of home to the hotel rooms as you're
traveling oh that's such a cool story
how it started and then expanded from
there and five years later we're here so
you know five years now of the business
five five five or six give and take
we're in a few retail stores Congrats
yeah we do a lot of
cent branding where companies kind of
asked us to make their own particular
fragrance where their office or for
their company so we have a few lines
that are salons few hotels so so they'll
work with you to do a specific scent
that they want for their environment
correct and then to teach us about a
couple of the scents that yeah if we go
yes let's do it this is our San
Francisco candle let's bring it let's
bring it okay so this is a San Francisco
candle iconic Aidan Ashford right by a
Haight and Ashbury so tell me how it
smells like it's got a hippie vibe so
that's what hippie incense five yeah
this one right here is San Diego is one
of our top sellers this is San Diego the
sea sand and surf so it's a sea salt Wow
nice the sea salt with a little bit of
verbena and juniper so it's a nice combo
this one in particular this is Chicago
famous popcorn mix that is inspired by
Garrett Garrett's popcorn the caramel
and cheese mix Wow how do you guys put
together these sons my personal memories
of how I remember the cities how it
smells how it smells to me the city
smell to you so I had translated into a
candle so how I remember them by
basically like Maui that's like Maui
flowers in LA yeah so it's orchids
plumerias so that's kind of how it goes
wow this so cool and then will you just
see these other ones these are Oh lovely
espera dawn so it's there yeah so
they're inspired by them basically and
then these over here are our little
exotic blends so if you see there's like
first date a curious blend of amber and
musk there's a little theme here so
first day and then you go between the
sheets between the sheets then you go
pillow top and then pillow talk and then
the next one that's coming soon
maybe regret or bad
decisions no I'm kidding move a little
bit yeah so okay so they're right here
okay first day between the sheets pillow
talk and if ever I if I ever make a
fourth one it'll be bad decisions that's
great so then where where can people
find six seven six candles come six
candles not come if you're ever at the
airport Napa Valley Farms carry em as
well six seven six candles calm six
seven six candles gone thank you so much
for talking to us this has been super
fun you can find this all youtube.com
forward slash simulation series yeah
you'll see it there thank you that thank
you
all that was cool all right let's do
another one let's go over here hi guys
hi how's it going proper herbal skincare
can we talk to you guys a little bit
awesome thank you hi guys hello we're
actually a live streaming right there
and those cameras yeah what what's your
name Anna I'm Alan good to meet you
honest so what is this all about what's
proper herbal skincare so proper herbal
infusions is all-natural coconut
oil-based products we make some of the
whipped body butters and locally
harvested lavender hydrosols are from
here but the rest of these are from the
Philippines and I'm working with this
company manufacturer is really super
they're working on building up the
community grassroots getting people to
work teaching them how to do Gila
massage which is traditional Filipino
massage and they're creating these great
natural products that are so good for
you that you could literally shower in
the forest or in the river and it would
be alright and then where was the
inspiration for you to start this um
actually you know I'm a designer I
wasn't really sure this hope was my
thing but I tried the virgin coconut oil
papaya bar and I put it right on my face
and left it there for 10 minutes
thinking I was just gonna have a facial
explosion but instead
it just made my skin so nice and it was
all natural and the people who are were
manufacturing it were just the coolest
people doing such good for the community
and that was it I was hooked and I've
actually gone all natural since then I
love these products okay and then how do
you make I mean this is a lot of unique
products so yeah do you make them all by
hand so these are made in the
Philippines in Peru laguna and they are
there there are people who are creating
them by hand every process is looked
over very clean facilities others I do
make here and yes so everything is made
by hand whether it's by me or by my
folks my partner's over in the
Philippines so yes nice and then what's
the give us again an idea of all the
different like a assortment so again
everything is me me I just want to
quickly have some cameras over there and
so we just said yeah yeah thank you
so if you guys are just talking yeah
yeah we just wanted to see us a line of
sight that's it yeah thank you thank you
thank you so much so it's all coconut
oil-based products and starting over
here we have a veggie glycerin with
coconut oil chunks premium coconut oil
soaps of virgin coconut oil soaps
okay so coconut oil soap is actually
something that is yes
coconut oils soap it it's actually the
oil from the coconut so included to have
a good soap you always start with an oil
or you know sometimes it but coconut oil
is like the best oil right so that's
what we eat it every day like justly and
we're we're using it in all of these
natural products so nowadays with all
these chemicals going into all of our
products we have no chemicals in any of
these products they're all-natural you
can use these products and feel good
because you know your your skin's not
going to react
they're essential with scented with
essential oils so everything is
all-natural like I said you could shower
in there in the river shower in the
forest or you could use the gray water
to water your houseplants and it
actually would be good for them rather
than killing them and then what are
these done - um so then we have
aromatherapy oils a natural insect
repellant hydrosols which are
essentially it's the natural insect
repellent that's cool most a lot of
people are complaining about how it's
not the non natural ones yeah because
basically what people do is they put
pesticides all over their body which
it's not really something you want to be
doing right so this actually is just
using natural essential oils with the
coconut oil base again and so you're
actually moisturizing and conditioning
your skin instead of putting a pesticide
you're using what nature already gave us
so Nature has already provided
everything that we need and all we need
to do is harness it harness it
yeah that's we love talking to our
guests about things like ethnobotany
right and so the ideas just there's been
billions of years of evolution of all
these different cool ways to piece
together different plants and materials
that we can then use that are is
completely natural that indigenous
people have been knowing and using for
so long exactly exactly and that's what
we have here this is just an infusion of
coconut oil with these natural herbs
that are protecting us and they're
really good for us so instead of
poisoning our bodies instead of
poisoning the earth we're healing I love
that and then where can people find
herbal infusions I'm so proper herbal
infusions calm we're online proper
herbal infusions calm yeah and we're
also at different little shops here we
have a stockist on our website so you
can check and see which stores were
stocked out here in the city and around
and then it great events like this yeah
and what do you think's the importance
of doing cool things like the community
markets um you know every time that you
reach out to the community and honestly
I think we don't have enough of this
type of stuff here in the United it's
super cool you get to bring everybody
out see what everyone is up to and
instead of supporting big giant
corporations you get support families
and community
artisinal on it thanks so much for
talking to us we really appreciate it
thank you
you can find the content on youtube.com
forward slash simulation series
simulation series yeah I find it there
we're live streaming right now so you'll
see it there and and then also um one
more time again on where you can find it
the product proper herbal infusions calm
proper herbal infusions calm okay
excellent
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank you I don't but you can
again if you yet or and you can also if
you want to grab okay cool yeah yeah
okay we'll go down
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
thank
so yes hi oh yeah yeah yeah - fine yeah
yeah totally so it's yeah on YouTube
okay and then it's youtube.com and
forward slash simulation the forward
slash is this one so go like that and
then go like that and then yep and
simulation series ser IES yeah ER IES
yep yep that's it you'll find it right
there yeah yeah okay thank you guys bye
thank you okay so alright so again
everyone we are live here at
undiscovered SF's creative night market
it is so fun being here it's it's we're
talking to people about all the cool
stuff that they're doing the filipino
markets help the whole Filipino culture
is helping to put this together bringing
together community from around San
Francisco and it's so cool because it's
happening right in the simulation series
studios
back back alley and there's all
different types of retailers that are
here there's all different types of
performers that are here food trucks
that are here it's bringing the
community together it's so so so
beautiful and fun we're asking people
about their thoughts on the direction of
our world which is a very fun big
question to ask people so all right
let's see if we can talk to some more
people
hi guys do you want to talk to us about
your thoughts on the direction of our
world that's a big one that's a big come
talk to us for a little bit come talk to
us for a little bit just a couple
minutes okay okay okay okay
Roger
but I Alan how are you Alan Alan talk
back to me hi Ron
hi yeah we're having a conversation now
live Alan on TV just to let everybody
know in the studio and he's out in the
streets and who is just kinda winging
this by the seat of our pants let me do
a double shot here here we are right
without different care it would it would
have been so great for the audience to
also have heard the way that Ron was
directing thanks for doing what you do
I'm gonna talk to some more people see
what about the products that are out
there and yeah yeah yeah okay now back
to you Alan back to you al all right hi
guys hello I'm I'm Alan I host a show
called simulation and we're talk we're
live now we're talking to different
people about their thoughts on the
direction of our world do you want to
talk okay okay maybe on the way back let
us know hi guys
okay okay okay hey you guys are excited
it come talk to us go talk to us yeah
yeah yeah you work we're live we're live
we're recording you guys eating right
now on on YouTube so
do you guys want to talk to us for a
little bit my name's Alan we host the
show called simulation we talk to
different people about their thoughts on
the direction of our world did you guys
like to maybe answer a couple of the
questions for a little bit you join the
food yeah what what is the food what is
the food they're burritos okay okay
looks like good food all right all right
thank you thank you hi guys hello hi hi
guys I host a show called simulation
we're currently talking what wait and
wait and see that again what just
happened so we went to a website and say
that they saw us at the podcast so I
just want to whoever that person is I
got no shout out to the person that went
directly to I guess first it from and we
have an Austin candle so I don't know an
awesome candle too so oh that's so cool
and thank you for telling us that all
that so cool look wrong wrong look back
there it six-on-six yeah that's so great
yeah so great they got the message I
love it I love it oh that's so nice that
it came back and told us that wow that's
a quick feedback loop that's really
interesting that if someone's watching
the live stream and they enjoy that
product that's from talking about they
can just reach out on the website right
away and say hey I watched that podcast
that was live that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool
20 years ago that wasn't happening now
there's democratized people here has
happening all the time it's very
interesting okay
hi Malaya hi guys hi I'm Alan what's
your name Rolando hey do you guys want
to talk to us we have a show called
simulation where we're right we're right
across the if you want to talk to us
about your products our show is live
streaming right now where where's the
owner
Malaya is owner right here what's her
name Pia Pia okay hi Pia
hi I'm Alan do you want to talk about
Malaya botanicals on our show we're live
streaming right now the cameras are
right behind you yeah the bun looks
great here okay Pia come on come on over
PA come on over you look great you look
fantastic
[Music]
okay view hi I'm Alan I host a show
called simulation we're live streaming
from across the street right now talking
about how cool this market is asking
people thought-provoking questions and
we see we're talking to some of the
vendors as well and we saw Malaya so how
did what is this and how did it all get
started sure so this is a CBD wellness
product line I started four years ago so
my background I'm a marketing consultant
and so I was hired four years ago to the
marketing for the cannabis industry and
so I was doing that for a few years I
joined the board of director for a small
farmers association I was helping them
with their marketing and getting
licensing and then I got injured as a
triathlete and the doctors were giving
me 2400 milligrams ibuprofen so I went
from doing like a fireman's and biking
to almost bedridden and so CBD is what
helped me with my injuries as CBD helps
you to your injuries and then you
started your own entrepreneurship brand
with it
okay so teach us about what this is now
so so this is our pain cream so we have
four different kinds there's be a pain
cream this is a 500 milligrams of CBD
hold the mic I'll help you out you
showcase the products so we have pain
creams here
CBT as well so we can take the pain crib
and rub it on the area where you feel
pain and within five to ten minutes of
pain will go away yes and then how much
CBD is infused in the pain 500
milligrams okay 3.8 ounce container fine
8 ounces and then you have CBD oil also
we have CBD oil so we have a teacher
it's 500 milligrams also okay so this is
the tincture teacher you something will
you put it under your tongue yes and any
any it doesn't happen overnight but over
a period of time it starts to help with
your inflammation the helps manage
stress anxiety and other and then is
this all online as well what's your
website so our website is
www.antakungfu.com okay this has CBD
infused as well it does has 20
milligrams we have three different kinds
muscle pains muscle joint pains we have
one for stress and also helps people who
has psoriasis and eczema you have hair
care - okay ready Terri I'm Scott
inflammation imbalance and also stress
and so unfortunately see buddy will not
help with the hereditary aspect of it
but it helps with the call if the hair
loss caused by inflammation imbalance
and stress that will promote promote CBD
will help promote hair growth and we'll
need one of these for our director
producer Ron Vargas for his hair growth
[Laughter]
[Music]
awesome Malaya
oh what's that way this one is a
lubricant yes yes what do we use the
lubricant for sharing oh my god you know
my dad's a deacon well there's a variety
of products that can be used for
whatever purpose is so and then lastly a
moisturizer and the face mask for sure
gbts anti-aging properties so you know
so this one is infused with CBD and I'm
moisturizer so it helps with your health
hydrate your skin and moisturizes it and
some age spots congratulations on
starting a great brand with a great
story yeah so Malaya botanicals dot-com
thank you so much for you we really
appreciate it thank you thank you and
you can find the content youtube-dot-com
forward-slash simulation series okay and
then you can email us if you'd like
simulation series as you know
it's so cool talking to entrepreneurs
and hearing about their journeys and
their stories and why they decided to
start the brands that they did and what
exactly it means to them it's super fun
and there's so many of them hi guys
Johnson come on come on we're we're live
right now you want to talk let's every
because Johnson from highways everyone
so what do you think is the importance
of community markets like this oh the
importance of community market like this
is the is is to keep the to keep the
message going to to bring people bring
more awareness to these type of events
and keep the the inner community
developing like it's and and we need
this on Stephenson Street we do if
you're listening we need this on Stevens
desert we need more of this we need more
community-based activities just to
reintroduce the community back into the
street this area period yeah yeah this
in highways is great there actually we
had John on the show I'm rock on the
show and they're actually the same
building as us you guys are the same
building as us and we both spend a lot
of time here in the back alley and it's
nice to see community coming together
like this for fun dancing there's kids
dancing this vendor service you know
what I mean it's so much differently
this today so yeah so we hope to see
more of this around and then give us
your thoughts on the direction of our
world to the direction we're going
digital what does that mean blockchain
crypto currencies
that's that's that's on a financial tip
but just our world period I don't know
how so
that's crazy okay so digital that's kind
of where the big thing for you is yeah
so like everything about you is already
like there's a little like digital twin
of you on the internet already that
they're like watching something like
that I mean what do you mean how like
myself or a natural you you live in
person yeah they have you mapped like
what your behaviors are where you've
traveled to what messages you've sent
who you've called yeah if you do those
things on centralized platforms that can
be tracked tracked and traced by those
market providers then yeah but if you
use like sort of decentralized platforms
to to do things like these specialized
platforms to buy things then no one can
really check that it was you that bought
it and then which ones are we talking
like signal for messaging and like what
are we talking with protonmail like what
are you using that's not being tracked
I'm actually not using anything that's
not being tracked like supposedly I know
this is not true but supposedly they say
that whatsapp is not being tracked that
it's encrypted encrypted on both sides
you know these folks got you on the
database in today's book you know so you
never know you never really know what's
going on with them they attach your
phone number to it and that you know
that's all that's all I really need
right do we do we have any any specials
on highways right now for those that are
local yeah $100 ounces $120 ounces
well 124 now oh yeah a hundred hundred
dollars we have some for me to bring one
down to Ron everyone paint patrons
simulation series to PayPal's below so
you can get Ronnie some of the cannabis
yeah let's do it yeah let's do it
cannabis for all such a good deal in the
local Bay Area from highways thanks
Jonathan tree she ate yeah no problem I
was a lot of fun
got me on the spot
sounds good sounds good
see ya hi guys I host a show called
simulation we're live right now do you
want to talk to us for a little bit no
worries hi guys I host the show called
simulation we're live right now do you
want to talk to us for a little bit
we've we talked to different people
about like hard like fun questions or
thoughts on humanity we're talking to
this market today okay what's your name
Vivek come come over here - Vick thanks
for talking to us I'm Alan yeah no
problem but it's a fake thank you very
big what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world in what way
that's like you get to take it you get
to take all right I'll narrow it to like
just like I guess us as a country as of
right now but that's kind of tough cuz
everything especially with the internet
cuz like everything's kind of everywhere
I would say we're too focused in our
like own bubbles in a sense especially
because half the time we don't really
know what's happening especially with
like the way the internet works like all
these social media is the thing is they
want you to stay on their website longer
cuz it makes some more money
so the [ __ ] that you see on can I cuss
sorry okay alright so like the [ __ ] that
you see on like those websites are
basically things that are like things
that you're more likely to click so you
stay on there so whatever your beliefs
are you're gonna see more of those type
of articles and whatnot so you're more
likely to click on them and reassure
yourself okay I am right and like feel
happy about yourself in a sense you
family so it's like easy to get stuck in
those like loops and you can't it's and
we get out of the echo chambers out of
the echo chambers I mean all you can I
mean the first step really is just to
educate people but that also faces a
problem because it depends on who's
teaching it right so it's it's tough I
mean I don't I don't have the answer for
this I think it's going to be more of
like
like it has to be like a lot of people
coming together some type of overhaul
maybe like the internet gets like a
little bit more refined in the sense
that whatever it gets on there is
actually like double checked as in like
being a real thing and then what about
what can we do on a day to day basis to
stay out of our echo chambers to maybe
increase our empathy open up our hearts
feel more like a global village yeah
talk to more people like I think like
like I came to the city on Bart and
everyone's just like nose deep in their
phones like you like even like maybe
like 10 years ago taking Bart like you
just have like random conversations with
people I'm not saying like that doesn't
happen now but like it's just very
infrequent now and just talking to more
like different people and not like
getting ready to pounce on them by like
judging them or anything just listen to
their story and see their like
perspective because perspectives is
everything and your perspective is
really based on your own moral code and
what you believe is more important than
other things right so it's really hard
to like like that's kind of why I like
everything has like a label in a sense
right because it's easier to say okay I
am this party or I am this apartment
yeah yeah yeah say like I am this party
or I am this party cuz it's kind of like
an umbrella term for like everyone but
the thing is one like for example one
Democrat might have different beliefs
than another Democrat right it's still
varies there's like nuances between that
it's just that no one has all the time
in the world to like actually learn
about everything so it kind of comes
down to like whoever's like
in like the place of power in a sense
they have to be more responsible and
actually like listen to the majority
people that they govern and actually
answer to them rather than what they
think is like right or not and what do
you think's the importance of community
markets like this Oh like this oh it's
it's everything it's Trenton's who
people are their identity because I mean
like especially me being like a like I I
was born in India but I came here when I
was three months so like technically I
consider myself like American but like I
was born in India so Mandi and it's kind
of like that weird territory but like
I'm more comfortable here it's like
obviously there's like whole thing about
like yo what's my identity Ville you
face that stuff like growing up but like
seeing stuff like this obviously like in
the Filipino community Indian community
whatever community it is it's like it's
it's really nice just like seeing people
come together yeah because it's for
whatever it is you might have like this
community this community has a term but
like what brings people together it's
more of like common like upbringing
common like morals and whatnot so like
that's kind of how people gravitate to
each other in a sense right and I think
I gotta say I love the pink this is
beautiful brother thanks for talking to
us
yeah no problem you can find it
youtube.com forward slash simulation
series if you want to find my search
live thanks for talking to us well thank
you thank you you too
hi guys I'm Alan I host a show called
simulation we talk to different people
about interesting questions like you
guys want to talk to us for a little bit
we're streaming right we'd love to hear
some of your thoughts you're welcome
you're welcome thank you thank you
hi guys hi my name's Alan I host a show
called simulation do you want to talk to
us for a little bit
no worries maybe the little guy wants to
talk to us though the kid got upset when
I asked him to come on the show he gave
me a thumbs down - hey guys
I host a show called simulation I'm Alan
do you want to talk to us for a little
bit on the show Eddie Eddie we're gonna
ask you what your thoughts are on the
direction of our world to start and then
we'll ask you about the community market
come on perfect come on Eddie come talk
to us for a little bit we're right over
here just a couple minutes Eddie Eddie
thank you for coming out and talking to
us face-to-face this way towards the
cameras Eddie what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world you know it
kind of makes me sad to be an American
sometimes a little bit it really does
well partly because I feel like the
administration specifically Trump
doesn't understand the people and we're
more galvanized more than we've ever
been and I don't think we're focused on
the big issues and Trump is just
dividing us based on rhetoric based on
hate based on misogyny and I just don't
think that's the world we should be in
that's not what makes America great so
that's where I come from yeah and then
what about like day to day what can we
do to become better humans I just think
we should be nicer to each other like I
feel like we live in a world where
social media has changed the way we view
things and we live in a place where
we're like more isolated and we feel
we're more comparing ourselves everyone
when honestly I feel like if we just
took a step back and realize we are
better today than we were yesterday and
that should be our measurement of like
our self-worth all right compare
yourself to who you were yesterday
anybody else in the world like to who
you are and I know progress is slow and
changing me difficult but I think we all
we all have in a
to protect ourselves better in the
future and then Eddie what do you think
this is importance of community
gathering like this I feel like it's
really great to like expose yourself the
cultures that you're not familiar with
like for example like I'm not Filipino
but it's great to be here and to like
understand something it's really
different than Who I am and I think this
makes us feel the unknown become known
right I think a lot of time to think why
we have such polarizing beliefs because
we don't get a chance to know the other
side I mean like I do it myself like I
only subscribe to information that's
like Democratic based or liberal or
however you want to spice it but I think
if we took a chance just to learn other
cultures other beliefs we will not have
these I guess prejudice our based on
nothing I love it because we all come
from the same origin on this plan we do
to to really be able to embody that and
enjoy each other's cultures and share
that together love that Eddie thank you
very much for talking to us I appreciate
you taking the time cue thank you and
you can find us at youtube.com for slash
simulation series if you want to see the
content awesome great Alan Alan thank
you hi guys I'm Alan I host the show
called simulation we talk to different
people about their thoughts something
set
hey guys hey we're actually doing a live
stream right now and we would love to
talk to you I know you're you're
depressed
yeah yeah oh okay okay bye guys hi guys
hi guys hello
what's up guys my name is Alan I host a
show called simulation we like we're
asking different people
thought-provoking questions we're live
streaming right now do you want to talk
to us for a little bit a couple minutes
just a couple just a couple questions
what's your name right what's this Pat
you have a channel it's right behind you
look at the camera where we're live
right now we're we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna ask a question we usually
talk we usually interview scientists or
entrepreneurs or artists or people in
their fields perfect yeah right Patrick
Patrick turn tweeter just a minute we
can do a short Patrick so what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
oh man you know what I think at first I
would say oh it's not going very well
but that's just kind of how I am like
anybody could say that it's not going
well but what can we do better I mean a
lot of things I mean those things are
small like I would want more I mean if I
to be simple to be let's say less less
wasteful like use of plastic and
products and maybe to more like things
based on social justice more economic
justice environmental justice so yeah
that's one there's something there but
they take a long time to happen what
could we do in our day-to-day behaviors
I just be more mindful of aware whether
it's how we see people I achieve people
what products we use what products we
don't use what business that we support
and the opposite don't support yeah and
what are your thoughts on the importance
of the markets like this community
gathering they're very important because
also where we're a you know we're
supporting local artists artists of
color as opposed to like going to Amazon
Target giving them money so they matter
and it's like I said it's
entrepreneurial there it's these aren't
people that are from money and they're
just regular people like you and I so
yeah that's beautiful thank you very
much yeah you can find the content
youtube.com for our simulation series
simply said yeah thanks guys
thank you
hi guys my name is Alan I'm live
streaming right now on our YouTube
channel do you want to talk to us for a
couple minutes okay okay
hi guys my name is Alan we're doing a
live stream right now asking people
questions do you want to talk to us for
a little bit oh you got a little yeah it
comes you come back
why wait wait a second Edie I just came
back whoever that guy on our website
placed on the order I want to say thank
you for supporting small businesses
that's all thank you rob
well how cool is it that we now have
these very fast turnovers with it like
you can just market something and
someone they'll see it online and check
in with it that's great it's like the
Wow Wow and then it's just so wife's -
what's the wife's name Tennessee
Tennessee awesome I want to just go say
hi to Tennessee quick hi Tennessee hi
I'm Allen it's so good to meet you I was
just talking to Ed a little bit about
you know you guys in the story and stuff
I just wanted to say hello to you too
said something but a certain Nathan from
Austin place an order
I guess he's watching you guys from
Austin shout out to Nathan from Austin
that's so yeah thank you so much Thank
You Nathan that's so cool and it was
really cool ed was telling me about your
story and the flight attendants and how
you guys started this company based on
you guys wanting to have like a nice
home sent inside of those homes and
other people latching onto that I
smelled some of them we were talking
about them they're really nice so I
wanted to at least share that with
[Music]
Tennessee Annette thank you both so much
thank you thank you
we wish you guys great success yes yes
Wow
so cool and order was even placed right
over hello hi hi guys my name's Alan I
host a show called simulation we're live
streaming right now do you want to talk
to us for a little bit okay don't worry
okay thank you
hi guys hi my name is Alan I host a show
called simulation we're actually live
streaming right now over there yeah you
want to talk to us or a little bit come
on come on over come on over
join us yes join us right over here what
are what are your names
I'm Ren Ren Ren Polito Rena Pulido Rena
Chloe Chloe
okay I'm Alan okay Ren Rena and Chloe
what are your guys thoughts on the
direction of our world it's gonna get
better
we had to keep hoping it's going it's
getting it's getting to where people are
talking about things that we shouldn't
we have we don't really usually talk
about so that's better that's good right
so we know we know what we gotta do and
we're gonna go there there you go I
think that's a good natural neutral and
then what would you say are these most
important things that we can do um
support each other you know I think um
it's the middle class if anything you
know support you know everybody but some
middle class needs to be more out there
because I think what the middle class is
like we're so comfortable we're
comfortable where we are so we're kind
of like we don't really know what's
below us and above us we like alright
well they affect us but not really but
middle class and stick together and be
more out there I think so I don't know
yeah think about the world think about
the environment like that's important
why waste time like being about Mars
when Earth is already like what they
need us you know what I mean we don't
need the other planets think about us
first a lot of the indigenous cultures
that we get to talk to on the show they
tell they teach us that we're
disconnected from nature from source and
and because of that is a reason why we
have so many of the issues in our world
is that resume
we just started hanging out with nature
a lot more often because it's like it's
such a hidden gem and we need to be out
there and really preserve what we have
you know you know like we own a home
like people did get on home we you know
but in the day I was like you know what
I just want to be an event living in a
river like by the river like that's like
a dream life for me right now but we
can't do it because we gotta keep going
what do you guys think are the the
importance of gathering community like
this very very important we were just
talking about it well to the question
that you just asked before like
indigenous history like I just went to
this performance that was based on like
the history of Filipinos and like like
where they were from in the forest and
like I got to see all these dances and
it really like opened my eyes so that
there's so much more and that US youth
is the voices are the voices to that and
keeping it alive yeah yeah to preserve
it from the most indigenous days and to
still remember it so yeah having events
like this keep it alive it's really nice
thank you thank you all for talking to
us we greatly appreciate it
if you want you can find us on the live
stream as was on youtube.com for /
simulation series yeah it is live now so
okay thank you very much thank you
hi
and we can even we gonna open up the
livestream on the phone and show it to
them too
all right so we got some people watching
the livestream
let's so let's make it so so there's our
livestream we'll show it to people will
be fun to do that all right all right
all right cool so let's [ __ ] let's show
that to people as we talk to them hi
guys hi guys hello
hello hi my name is Alan I host a show
called simulation we're talking to
people
hi guys my name's Alan rose nation right
now do you want to talk to us for a
little bit we're live right now if you
want to talk to us cool no worries
stories hello I my name's Alan we're
hosting a show called simulation right
now over there we're live right here
so do you want to talk to us for a
little bit regarding we want to ask you
a couple questions about the world about
this community market things like that
yeah I don't know if I'm capable of
doing those Thanks yeah just we'll have
some fun kick it talk for a little bit
let's do it what what's your name what
Daniel yes okay cool
I'm Daniel my name's Alan Daniel what
are your thoughts on the direction of
our world world I don't know it's kind
of like in the United States it's a
little different I would like as a world
traveler I like to see you know there's
a lot of things that I actually like
seeing you know out of you know out of
the country wise but what does that do
when you go out of the country and you
get to see other things it actually
humbles you in terms of things that you
see here in the United States this is
actually a good opportunity like what I
like seeing you know away from here like
the United States why's this little big
community but it's it's small
I don't know the US and in itself is
like somewhere I don't know if I would
actually see myself living like five
years ten years from now and why just
because of you know I want to say
politics but yes it is but yeah what
aspect of the politics just the
direction it is right now currently it
could change in the next five years next
four years especially with next
presidential election but in terms of
what it is right now it's kind of for me
Trump whites it's not it's not something
that I like oh yeah youtube-dot-com
forward-slash simulation series yeah and
then what about dinner what about
day-to-day what can we do day-to-day to
make the world better with our behaviors
it's tough because here in the
California we live in a bubble like it's
not like we live in the Midwest or the
East Coast or California in itself is
it's very predominantly like tech based
like a lot of people in a lot in the in
the Midwest they don't see what we see
regularly right so it's it's kind of I
don't know it's it's it's very strange
maybe we got to do some like humbling
ourselves and increase our empathy with
other people's viewpoints from around
the world I think it's way it's hard
it's hard to say because I think one of
the things that we deal with nowadays
people don't even want to deal with
California in itself they say okay
you're from California you're you know
you have a biased opinion on stuff so
it's
it's hard and then maybe the last
thought is what are your thoughts on the
importance of community markets like
this actually you know what community
markets like this is actually great like
being in Cambodia being in the
Philippines thing in Vietnam these are
the things that bring community together
like you see it now like I came from the
South Bay being in in San Francisco this
is actually something that's actually
really good because it's like I have
friends that are Japanese and right now
is the Obon festival and it's like those
environments actually bring you know
groups together those cultures together
without actually having to like enforce
it yeah you know so it's like yeah it's
it's just one of those things like I I
actually enjoy and I actually try to
like embrace those things and have more
of around the world thank you very much
for talking to us
Thank You Danny Alan Alan thank you
denigan you can find us on youtube
comment section thank you thank you
thank you really appreciate ER oh thank
you thank you thank you we appreciate it
thank you
all right opening back up the stream all
right
hi guys hello hello is this lraleigh
it's a Elle Raleigh hi hi hi we're live
streaming right now look how cool is
that
our cameras over there hey what's your
name Elle Elle Raleigh yes I'm I'm Allen
it's so good to meet you thank you so
what is Elle Rowley all about well L
Rowley is a fashion brand with a mission
to recreate the created by up succulent
upcycling fabric to help reduce sex
always so I deconstruct it and I remake
everything whoa upcycle material
okay so then upcycle materials to teach
us about that so obstacle material is
pretty much like t-shirts and clothes
that are unwanted and the reason why I
do it is because the fashion industry is
the number two leading polluting
industry in the world and so close last
a lifetime and so I believe that by
recreate recreating clothes we can do a
lot in helping protect the environment
well okay so you can take clothes that
are then not being used anymore and you
kind of kind of like recreate really
cool unique styles yeah show us some
yeah and yeah let's just show it show it
this way whoa yeah it's all just pretty
much made of strips so I cut them up and
I break them up multifunctional you can
wear it this way or this way and then
you have your pockets wait does it wait
what does that say it says recruit we
create all up sites not your logo your
slogan yes cool slogan it's beautiful
okay and you wow you took so many pieces
from okay let's yeah show us another one
we would love to see more it's beautiful
in San Francisco of course this is your
Niners right so you take t-shirts yeah
being us yeah and then again you can
wear it either way this way or this way
so these are called the fly dresses why
dresses okay now we have a sweater and
then you have your pockets on the sides
as well so you add pockets yourself to
them yeah okay we ought to make it
functional
whoa I do
yeah the t-shirts right here so the guys
can wear it yeah and then the women just
wear it as dress is so I got shirts I
got crops I got tank tops all that fun
stuff
meet my new line I just released an
off-white collection so what collection
it's my off-white not basic t-shirts
off-white yeah what'swhat's the website
Oh L rallied L rally calm cool yellow ER
al i.com for all of these up cycled
clothing yes yes yes and if you follow
me on Instagram and watch my stories you
can actually see me create every single
thing here oh you have videos of you
creating them high-five your content
your content Queens write my story they
don't really do it like YouTube or
anything like that but if you follow my
stories that's how people watch what I
make they DM me from there and they kind
of get first pick into everything I
again well you can just you could even
just save the stories and then just
upload those into a YouTube video as
well and then the whole process from
like well subscribe in promotion there
you guys more people will too because
they'll like to see you doing upcycle
clothing in like videos that aren't just
temporary
right well thank you you're super
welcome this is so neat it's actually
it's it's like if Ron can also see all
of these L has pictures
Ron's our director producer handling
those robotic cameras but yeah and then
what's the Instagram handle to just ller
al
beautiful okay cool and I also want to
say like mathematically this is very
beautiful too because you can take what
is being upcycle there's clothing and
then you basically have an infinite
amount of combination potentials with
the clothing the hardest part upcycling
is scaling cuz I can't make a lot of the
same thing so it definitely is a lot of
a kind which a lot of I think my
customers really appreciate definitely a
story to it they watch the process and
like dude I'm gonna little it's gonna
have this is great and they're also
making a big impact into our environment
as well
they say to make a brand new t-shirt it
takes like 700 gallons of water or I
think it's yeah to produce and that's
like enough water to feed a person for
one day so luckily makes a big
difference you're such a cool
entrepreneur you're a great designer too
[Music]
thank you you're super welcome what do
you what are your thoughts on the
importance of the community gatherings
like this well I'm all about you know
like I kind of learned about this by
being part of the Filipino group and
we're all about community and so I think
if we have any chance of bringing people
together learning about not only like
community but our culture as being
Filipino I think is amazing and so I
really enjoy just being part of
something like this right we gotta get
out of the house it's not Francisco it's
pretty beautiful you know like I get to
meet you yeah so funny
thank you so much oh thank you thank you
thank you you're so cool I'm telling you
this is cool stuff everyone definitely
check out lraleigh whoo I love it thanks
so much you're so cool thank you
you can find this live stream what's
happening on simulation series on
youtube so youtube.com forward slash
simulation series i'll send you a
message to maybe maybe we need to get
your boy your your boy may need to get
one of the flower Kosmos the
combinations i have lots of shirts like
these flowers plus like cosmic vibe plus
like children like trying to like
understand reality yeah
yeah stuff like that would be so cool we
actually are we already have like a
little tiny like merch store and it
would be cool to potentially add some
stuff from you and just like help you
guys yeah we all stuff like that we will
talk about it yeah I see a peeps oh
thank you thank you you're credible keep
up the great work keep up the great work
so cool up cycled clothing upcycle your
clothing make new combinations of the up
cycles in the clothing and and and be
more sustainable that way that's so cool
all right
let's ask more people to talk let's go
to another vendor actually
hi guys hi what's your name Francis I'm
Alan good to meet you I was just talking
to some of the vendors we have a live
stream that's happening right now on
simulation series so what are you guys
doing over here
these are our books beautiful eyes it's
an English early reader English two
Tagalog okay so you guys are a
publishing house and you're you have
books yes and okay and so this book is
called
beautiful beautiful eyes so it's a game
that parents play with their kids like
when their little babies kind of say
show me beautiful eyes and then they
blink you know so that's kind of like a
like a like a cultural kind of game yeah
so but anyways it's got like teaches you
like nose ears mouth but based on the
the initial game of show me your
beautiful eyes nice and then what about
journey for justice okay so that is
about Larry it Liang and he is one of
the most important Filipino American
historical figures that no one knows
about Wow
up until Larry it Liang Liang yeah and
do you know about the unit United Farm
Workers Union ufw it's like the major
were Farm Workers Union that's you know
global to this day but the initial
strike that happened in 1965 I believe
happened when the old mon owns the old
these old filipino farm workers who came
in the 1920s and you know they're old
men by this time in the 60s and 70s they
went on strike in Delano California and
said hey we want better wages and better
treatment and they went on strike but
you know they're old men at this point
and growers think hey we can break the
strike we'll bring in the Mexican
workers and break the strike but Larry
it Liang and the rest of the Monarchs
had great resolve and they went to Cesar
Chavez and his group at the time
soyou're Chavez was a young organizer
come join us in solidarity and together
we can make this better for everybody
and they were successful and five years
later the growers signs a contract
with acquiescing to their demands whoa
and so Wow stories like that so these
are the two that you guys are published
eight right now yes and full eyes and
journey for justice yes and you know
it's it's a my wife Gayle she's also the
author and you know she's head of the
publishing house and you know she does
we do consulting for people who'd like
to get their where is Gayle she around
no we have we have a she's she's going
to be doing our event tomorrow in
Oakland so we split we split and what
are your thoughts on the importance of
doing cool events like this community
well you know especially here in San
Francisco I'm a born and raised native
it's something that in the last 15 15
years 20 years that we've lost you know
the community here like the the local
community that's made San Francisco
world-famous you know like the the
inclusion the different personalities
and backgrounds and different like
income levels to be frank right but this
kind of like keeps keeps a tradition
alive of like what San Francisco was
built up to this point up until like you
know honestly the tech boom you know
kind of wiped out it's it's something
that historically I grew i we had a
restaurant where Sephora is on Powell at
the cable-car turn I grew up there we
had a restaurant there we had a
restaurant down the street here on the
backside on market we had a bakery in
Mission and you know so it's kind of
shocking to me at times when I come back
to the city it's like this is something
I don't recognize like you know the
culture it's like a monoculture now and
not that you know you know it's it's
change isn't good but we'd like to keep
some of the old flavor that made San
Francisco what it was
Thank You Francis yeah Francis where can
people find their publishing company
bridge and Delta comm bridge and Delta
comm like a and D bridge and Delta com
okay that's where everyone that's for
the books um thank you very much for
it's really appreciate talking to us and
you can find us on
youtube.com/theatrefolk
hybrid side hi Noah they're down there
okay okay we'll bring way brings some of
them to perform here okay I will do
dance competition yeah okay okay
hi guys
hey hey Ron I'm getting a little chilly
how long have we been streaming for
alright let's see maybe like one more
conversation yeah ha ha ha it's great
it's fun it's fun being out here it's
fun being out here
alright a lot lot last last last on
let's see if we can get a I'd like to
interview a dog if possible why why do
you have your camera in there we can
just interview you like okay okay
hello hi do you untie us for a little
bit
hello hey I'm Alan I host a show called
simulation you want to talk to us for a
little bit about the world in this
community market this type of stuff with
simulation oh there's a show called
simulation it's right over here yeah
what's your name
right now tell me about it that what's
the show yeah we just interviewed
different scientists entrepreneurs
artists different people in their fields
and for stuff like this we just come and
talk to people about their thoughts on
the world and their thoughts on the and
that came in our ask you that camera
tracks you like we walk this way that's
a robotic camera and yeah our our
recording studio is actually right in
here and so yeah so we just brought the
equipment out to him over what's your
name my name's Matt what's your question
yeah cool good to meet you Matt um Matt
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world there's people doing good
things and it's always that's always
inspiring but oh [ __ ] there's a lot of
work to be done yeah what do you think
we can do to move us in a more positive
trajectory get people out of cars on the
bikes get make it easier to build
housing in cities so people can live
close together close to resources and
good jobs and elect good people and then
what about like something that we can
embody on a moment-to-moment basis what
do you think could be good smile at
people thank people and it goes are
really good things to do yeah you can
butterfly effect massive change with
smiles and thank-yous yeah it's
gratitude and then what are your
thoughts on cool community gatherings
like this this is this is the stuff of
life this is a good stuff I'm gonna
probably run into good friends and yeah
this is great what a good use of an ally
better than storing cars isn't it yeah
thank you Matt thank you for talking to
us you can find this a youtube.com/
force life simulation series thank you
thank you
alright and well that was a lot of fun
everyone wow what a wide-ranging evening
this has been over at undiscovered SF's
creative night market you can find their
links in the bio below
we do check them out what a cool
gathering so many different diverse
vendors doing important things gathering
the community like this with children
with food with clothing with all
different types of cool things so thank
you Ron Vargas for producing and
directing back in the recording studio
we really appreciate it for everyone
that watched we greatly appreciate left
to your thoughts in the comments below
on what we talked about today on the
streets and pop around questions we
asked it for vendors we talked to one so
check out the links also to the vendors
as well check them out support them
support the artists entrepreneurs the
organizers the spiritual leaders in your
community support them help them grow
support simulation so you can keep doing
cool things like coming out on-site to
places like this and talking to
different people so support us our links
are below that's PayPal patreon
cryptocurrency design cool merchants get
paid all those links are below and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
very much thank you for tuning in we
will see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]